everybody I'm Kelly no it's more like
hey everybody I'm Kelly
[Music]
do you want to hear about your perks
yes I would like to um hear about those
please I gave Justina a muscle relaxer
and put her in her car she keeps
mumbling about feet but that's not a
forever thing I don't think maybe I'm
not following because my whole face has
gone numb and I just hear my own blood
why
since you have to use my phone
we've had several feet before but just a
sprinkling lightning is going insane
insane
[Music]
foreign
feet in the middle of the floor I'm
sorry if that sounded oversexual I'm
just looking for confirmation American
citizen nice my erections are fine thank
you this is crystal meth how do you guys
live on under 134 000 a year Jonah I'd
prefer if you didn't offer to shuttle
our employees to the abortion clinic oh
booge oh my God are you watching us
masturbate at work uh
Tom told me to tell you that his pug
Elmo fell into a sinkhole in the park
yes you can get pregnant from that angle
abortion abortion abortion abortion
abortion she dug your own Grace I'm
sorry
I have them switch
would help me visualize
a lot that's in
me you love me and then you dump me so
you could have sex with that pregnant
I'm an ally
hello
[Music]
I got a new life
it's not a Monster Match
[Music]
so when we do need to masturbate where
are we supposed to go toilet paper eggs
shaving cream I will kill myself before
I go back to 2D ultrasound okay I will
kill myself okay what if someone steals
a baby
[Music]
garbage
Dina's right eye on people
Ed is going it's gone on my wall I think
you
've got a Hitler I like to go extra make
sure everything's
up to code Glenda G nothing Glenn Gary
Glenn lost glenoma glental Sue
transglender
I'm you I used to Houston kangaroos
reveal
I'm bad y'all pretend I'm not here I
didn't set out to have a baby came from
sex
Tom Hanks is a space man his life is
saved by a bunch of nerds I wish I were
a mermaid
the last time we saw the thumb it was in
a tub of guacamole and how did they used
to you know
penis penis penis that
was something I shouldn't have said
I'm pregnant not today you're not okay
prom is there a prom around I hope you
die well I
put in the hoodie that covers my face
and I take the 47 bus line to a library
in a far away town
that I open a private browser on one of
their computers and Google home thinking
of killing her to see what mistakes
people usually make
Jesus
and
just dislike ain't good enough
[Music]
wanna ride time
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas tree have a happy place
[Applause]
[Music]
Merry Christmas kids it's a nightmare
Mrs Doubtfire Silence of the Lambs that
one where Nicholas Cage switches faces
and says he's going to eat a peach for
hours oh Forrest Gump that's a good
movie
I have a lot of cool sneakers and a very
active sex life get that camera out my
face obviously we're never gonna have
zero tramplings but we can have fewer
tramplings
do you remember your first period would
definitely kill a wall sorry son the
hell ride
anybody see Sully
I after a long day of work it's nice to
have a glass of wine and reach into a
stable boy's chest and pull out his
still beating heart you know my aunt was
warm with two vaginas
[Music]
hello Chicago
the arm strength of a chimp
G-spot
gay racist mean redhead
attention Cloud9 employees I am fine I
hope someone sets you all on fire and
you need a volunteer to put it out
sometimes when I'm playing The Sims I
give myself a family in the event of a
tornado you want to go straight for the
eye of it that is where it is safest
I want to be in puppy heaven
don't be a dick yeah I love waking up at
3am to eat Sandra's cold spinach
casserole
see you around a-hole
could you please shut up I'm I'm brexit
like thrusting their pelvises
[Music]
Marcus
is that your thumb
it was 1953 at Medical Science was all
the strange